hey everybody welcome to the great big
story youtube channel this is jillian
this is dave and here's the show
today we're gonna watch four great big
stories that are all about people
helping each other out sometimes we just
need a little help from our friends like
in this first story which is about a
prison in california that has a unique
program
let's watch
[Music]
the day i was going to sign my papers to
start working there were 3 000 inmates
out there working iron and i was like
what did i get myself into here
my name is carmen sheahorn i'm the
career technical and educator for
cosmetology at valley state prison for
men when i tell people that i work
teaching cosmetology in a men's prison a
lot of people are shocked by it they're
surprised they didn't even think that it
was available
this program takes approximately two
years and they have to have 1600 hours
completed in order to take the state
board of exam
there is a waiting list to get into this
class and in order to get into this
class an inmate has to meet certain
behavioral and educational um standards
when you come into my classroom you're
going to treat each other with respect
and common courtesy and
there's no boundaries in here
we're just going to relax your facial
muscles
and improve your blood flow throughout
your face my name is juan brizwolo i'm
here at valley state prison in chatura
california my favorite part of the class
is the skincare part of it which
includes like the facials eyebrows
makeup i like to to see my clients relax
and get comfortable with me it's
it's real personal and being in prison
they teach you not to touch each other
not to touch staff it goes against the
norm of what people see about prison on
tv you know ex-gang members
men with tattoos on their face all over
their body it's not something that you
see out there
working in a beauty salon is putting a
light on on a different side of the
prison system
i do treat them as human beings and i'm
not here to punish them i'm just here to
show them a skill that i have and it
happens to be in a prison
i have more empathy for people now
because of doing this type of work when
they get their license it's like i've
gotten my license for the first time all
over again
it's very rewarding
[Music]
for our next story we're gonna meet some
friends who aren't exactly human because
they're monkeys and they lend a helping
hand to people who have suffered from
injuries
so let's meet these monkeys and the
people
monkeys definitely feed off of your
feelings they know when you're feeling
down or when you're feeling funny it's
kind of an urban legend that people out
there training monkeys to help people
with disabilities but that really
happens
[Music]
i had my monkey casey for 10 years
in 2005 i was in a car accident
i enjoyed c1c2
the spinal cord with a
brain injury
i
couldn't move
really anything at all i couldn't talk
you know i've come over
our goal is to train and place capuchin
monkeys with people living with mobility
impairments
the program got its start really as an
experiment to say
we can train a dog to help somebody who
has visual impairment perhaps we can
train a primate to be the hands for
somebody who's had a spinal cord injury
we provide our monkeys at no charge to
our recipients
all of our monkeys are born into our
program typically a monkey will spend
about three to five years at the monkey
college learning tasks whether that's
fetching a phone or remote control off
the floor
helping somebody get something to drink
even something as complicated as
flipping the pages of a book
the monkeys do really act as hands and
give them that level of independence
back
you can imagine having a spinal cord
injury and all of a sudden you have a
monkey that's sitting on your shoulder
and you can finally feel that touch to
have a that monkey there is an
incredible bonding experience
when i couldn't move
casey did a lot for me
[Music]
now it's a lot of
emotional support
it's a lot of
companionship
casey is part of my family you know this
is a five pound animal that
is
extraordinarily helpful and brings joy
to my life
[Music]
our next story is about a guy named wade
who got a little helping hand from his
personal trainer and wade was not
supposed to live past 10 years old but
he is thriving and it's thanks to his
own determination and the help of the
people around him let's check out his
great big story
pull your shoulder blades back together
there you go
bye buddy and doing the exercises at the
gym it's really keeping me alive okay
three more and crazy if i wanted to stop
working out
at the gym i would probably do it by now
hey good
my name is wade mcrae washington
and i'm a professional bodybuilder
[Music]
let's see that program yeah
i don't know you can see my hands moving
i was diagnosed with cerebral palsy at
the age of 11 months
you know i know who scoliosis
at the age of 12.
when i first went to the doctor they had
told me
that i was not going to live 15 years
old
wade and i have been friends here at the
gym i'm his personal trainer
yes and he approached me with a very
serious tone and he told me that
he wants to do a bodybuilding show you
know one of my goals was to be a
viability the other one was to be a
professional wrestler but the wrestling
was too dangerous
in the beginning he didn't have the
control to get on a machine and just
work the body parts that we were
intending to work his hands and his feet
need to be stabilized you in yeah all
right so i got very creative and i built
up you know apparatuses that would fit
him in order for him to secure himself
and actually pull with the muscles that
i was wanting him to do
instead of it telling you what to do
you're telling it what to do
so let's tell it what to do again okay
okay the way i approach everything every
time i train i have to focus a lot
harder and a lot more of what body part
that i'm working on to make it work
right for me
wow
[Music]
it has improved a lot
the basic happiness that comes from
feeling strong and feeling able instead
of disabled is a big deal
my body has gotten a lot straighter i
have people tell me that i'm taller i'm
ever standing still my life is calm
seeing wade accomplish his pro status as
a bodybuilder was the most unbelievable
experience this was something no one
ever thought could happen
and it happened we made this happen
it's been amazing
and i'm blessed to have
a cochlear implant or free and latino i
enjoy being a pro bodybuilder it's my
lifestyle now
[Music]
so now we're gonna head over to china
and meet two guys who are really really
good friends these two guys lift each
other up in more ways than one let's
meet them
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thanks for watching these great big
stories with us and don't forget to
subscribe so just click on the horse
above us and please leave your comments
down below we'd love to hear from you
and hear what you think of the show
we'll see you next time bye guys
you